we need a decision ready right now
3:02 wait in his newest film eye on the
sky Academy award-winning director
Gavin hood it delves into the moral
legal and political questions
surrounding modern drone warfare
starring Helen Mirren Aaron Paul and the
late Alan Rickman in his final on-screen
role the film deftly portrays a single
drone mission from various perspectives
across the chain of command stamp is a
British citizen they want her alone they
cannot have her alive Frank I've tracked
her for six years this is the closest
I've ever got so we need to expand our
rules of engagement right now to protect
the civilian population a Hellfire
through that roof is our most effective
AMI
we have to know that we're legally in
the clear hood recently sat down with
recent TV to discuss his movie the
issues surrounding military drone
strikes and why guy Hibbert script
compelled him to take on the project
firstly I was enthralled by the ethical
and moral dilemma really since up I
found it incredibly well paced as a
thriller so it was a page-turner and but
it also kept presenting very different
perspectives on this drone strike
mission and just when I thought I knew
what I thought I would turn the page and
a character would say Tammy and will do
I think that and I got to the end and I
really wanted to talk to somebody about
it and of course there was nobody to
talk to because it was a script but I
thought if it's had that effect on me as
a read if I can execute it halfway
decently audiences might have a good
excellent experience and be left with
something to talk about afterwards
I love the debate because I think it's
an essential it's essential for us to
have these kind of debates I think so
much of our politics is so binary you
know and everybody stakes out of
position and that's that's not what
makes us great as a democracy what makes
us great is you know we engage with
other minds and we might actually find
ourselves learning something and what
guy script does so well I think is
present multiple points of view on a
particular scenario it doesn't in any
way preach to the audience tell them
what to think and you as the audience a
leftist jury here is what we have this
is accurately researched if you don't
know much about drone
fair you will i hope come to understand
a great deal more but you will be asked
to decide what you think as someone who
has qualms about current roles in the US
military overseas i want to believe that
these are the sorts of debates that
happen throughout the kill chain but
that seems a little far-fetched to me
can you talk a little bit about sure
it's a great question and let me try and
give you an overview first of all what
you see in the film is based on a
specific scenario that is set up in the
film what part of which is that it is
taking place in a friendly country kenya
into which a group of terrorists from
al-shabaab in Somalia have moved and are
plotting a suicide bombing within a
country with whom we as the United
States and Britain are friendly so we
are not in a theater of war so it's very
important to understand that if this
strike was taking place in Iraq or
Afghanistan as a defined conflict zone
you would not necessarily be engaged in
the same kinds of moral ethical and
legal conversations as you are if you
are targeting someone in Yemen or in
Pakistan or in Kenya so let's let's just
say that all drone strikes are not equal
um the particular scenario we have here
does involve targeting British citizens
and United States citizens that in
itself spawns an interesting
conversation because on the one hand
citizens of the United States or Britain
or horrified by the idea and probably
should be that their own citizens are
being targeted without judicial
oversight in the traditional sense on
the other hand as someone from another
part of the world it does not
necessarily play well from a propaganda
point of view to feel that the United
States is super concerned when they're
targeting one of their own citizens and
perhaps less concerned when they're
targeting someone from another country
so all of these questions legal
political are things that we need to be
talking about you know there are seems
to be a prevalent belief that due to the
nature of drone warfare someone's using
a joystick thousands of miles away that
perhaps it is so separated the actor
from the actions that this is a new age
of video game warfare meaning
essentially
your film does not seem to subscribe to
that notion yes I'm well levy the simple
answer to that question is that as our
military advisor drone pilot stroke f-16
pilot who had flown in the Iraq war said
to me Gavin when I used to fly in Iraq
yes there was a there was a limited fear
of being shot down it was unlikely but
it was there and so that fueled a
certain adrenaline but I didn't I I
could drop my payload and leave and now
as a drone pilot although I don't have
the physical um risk I'm not going to
get shot down but I am in this
claustrophobic space for up to fourteen
sixteen hours a day if an operations
going over or it's certainly eight to
twelve hours and I have to not only
target but I then have to stay and
identify bodies and hover over the
destruction and really own what I did
and even if I feel what I did was
necessary it's very traumatic to be
looking at body parts and trying to
identify and these pilots find that
distressing and maybe they should on one
level because it makes you accountable
it's not some grainy you know that
dreadful word that some pilots used on
those tapes that will eat bugs flat this
is a human life and I think as the as we
as we see these images more clearly
through technology it becomes harder and
harder to see it as just a video game or
as a bug splatter and we shouldn't you
mentioned drones as an unsettling weapon
mmm what what do you what do you mean by
unsettling well drones are unsettling
because we are only at the beginning of
where this kind of warfare is going and
you see in the movie the Reaper drone
that most people know with a Hellfire
missiles watching from 15 or 20,000 feet
you also see little bird that some
people say is that real well if you go
on YouTube you'll find that the
hummingbird with a little design to look
like a hummingbird with a camera was put
up on on YouTube by a defense contractor
I think almost five years ago that
technology is still being developed and
refined and especially the tiny bug
drone these micro drones I'm worried
that our film will be out of date if
we're not careful
because in the film the micro drone is
only used to send back visuals it's not
armed these microphones are very easy to
weaponize and the next step is that the
little micro drone targets you perhaps
with face recognition software as a form
we send them into a place we know who
we're looking for it finds you
blows little anthrax up your nose as it
flies by or detonates and where is this
going and it's not a one doesn't want to
use it as sort of scare tactics it is
where it's going what legal framework
will govern this new world of automated
warfare and what framework governs that
and are we all going to be living under
permanent drone surveillance in the
interests of security these trade-offs
are important conversations to have I
think the start of your movie is a
famous line from Aeschylus war truth is
the first casualty how do you think that
quote fits in with your thank you yeah
well the truth is very hard to get at
for us as individuals not because we're
not interested in the truth but because
we all see the world from a with a
particular background and wit and from a
particular position and one of the great
things in the film is that each of the
characters in the film is in a sense
true to the position they occupy Helen
Mirren is tracking has been tracking a
particular terrorist for six years I
spoke to military intelligence officers
some of whom have been tracking people
for ten years and they said to me one in
particular said to me Gavin you know in
this job when I've been watching someone
do what I consider to be terrible things
and I've been watching them and unable
to stop it
I don't even pretend that I can be
objective in certain moments that's why
I need the military lawyer for example
to step in and give me guidance because
sometimes I just quote want this person
off my list from the perspective of the
Foreign Secretary who's being asked to
approve this who will have to answer to
the British public which Ellen Moran's
character won't have to do it goes up
she's her world is private in the sense
he will answer to the public so he has a
different perspective yes we might
eliminate this particular terrorist but
if we take innocent life in the process
what's the political blowback from that
that's not a touchy-feely question
that's a very important question even
from a strategic point of view does this
help us win over a foreign population to
our way of thinking in order to win the
big battle or does it create a greater
problem and that's an important question
and not a question that is necessarily
on the mind of Helen Mirren in the way
that it's on the mind of say Ian Glen
who plays the foreign secretary when you
were 17 you were conscripted into the
South African oh yeah how does that
inform this film it's going back a while
I think I was a little naive as many
young people are at 17 about what
military service would mean I lost a
friend in Angola who was a closed school
friend I was not there when he died but
it had a profound effect on me in terms
of you know a sudden sense of mortality
and a beginning of questioning as to
what is the nature of this war what what
conflict are we actually involved with
and so I think having been in the
military I am interested in themes that
explore the the gray zone if you like I
don't think the world should be divided
into good versus evil and I think this
idea of this simplistic approach of I'm
right they're wrong is not helpful in
terms of strategically winning a what is
currently in the world a very
significant conflict a final question
what do you hope people will walk away
from the film thinking and talking about
I just hope they have a really great
discussion I I don't know what the
answer is
I think this is an evolving conversation
and I hope that if you if an audience
goes into this film not knowing much
about drones they will come out more
informed they will come out having
experienced a good movie and a good
thriller but they'll also be left with a
lot to talk about